hi
how are you i'm good thanks how are you
i am well i appreciate you talking to me
about this it's been fun to talk to you
over these movies as i would imagine
it's been for you to play them as an
actor yeah people just keep coming back
and we
every year it's frank
it's quite rare to get to
continue a film series like this that's
just about a couple in their
relationship when it doesn't involve
them saving the world or fighting
vampires or surviving the apocalypse
you just get to explore normal human
problems
what have you most enjoyed about the
opportunity to do these films to play
this character and to watch how they've
grown oh i think you've said it perfect
to explore normal human problems
uh and and to do something like this a
drama and a romance where you're just
playing chara like playing characters
and and it is melodramatic and that
these crazy situations happen that you
wouldn't expect happen in day-to-day
life but that's what's so
nice about it
um
yeah just playing real people with
problems
does anything most surprise you from an
acting standpoint that you didn't
realize might happen because you hadn't
done you know four movies telling the
same story before
well i'd done barely any movies before
this this was the first time i was the
lead in a movie and um i remember in the
first it was never like the first film i
was in every scene of the movie and i
think every shot except one
and
it was um
and the second and the third and the
fourth it wasn't like that because we
had more scenes where it was other
characters and it wasn't just from like
tess's point of view
but i remember
having that as my kind of introduction
to this in the industry i was like whoa
you know it's um
it's it's a lot and
uh
yeah i think i've learned i've learned
so much about
not just the hours involved but and and
the and
how difficult it is to make a film and
how difficult it is to make a good film
and just the amount of effort that goes
into it and all the different
departments and everything uh
yeah i've just learned lots of little
things i don't think i ever would have
been aware of if not through experience
what was it like to finish the last
scene on the last day knowing that that
would be it for these characters have
you officially said goodbye to this
character yet or does it not feel like
you're there yet since
the fourth film still won't be coming
out for a bit it kind of doesn't feel
like it's over and i think that's
probably you're right it's because the
fourth film hasn't come out
um i think once it does i'll feel more
done
like uh like we haven't even done adr
for the fourth film so it's not finished
finished yet but
um i i do feel like their
journey is done at least as far as i
i'm
aware
how did your first day on the first
phone compared to your last day on the
last film do you feel very different
personally now
um i feel very
similar in a lot of ways
uh i think the differences are probably
just well i'm older
i'm not living in the same place i know
things that i didn't know two years ago
uh
but
i i i really don't feel that different
i think i don't know if there's
something wrong with me
i think you're okay
it's wild that you shot this in bulgaria
during a pandemic what was it like to be
in a very foreign country have this
experience shoot with all these safety
protocols did it ever feel just very
alien
um
[Music]
it it it feels alien i think when
you get the first call that says you're
shooting in this country and it's
somewhere you've never been but after
you get there it's people are just
people it doesn't matter what language
they speak
and um
like
it it really does you kind of fall back
into it i mean uh there's little things
that you notice like oh like this food
is different or this or i don't
understand this reference but i think
you kind of human behavior is pretty
much the same wherever you go and i
think that um luckily we had a lot of
the same people with us and so when we
were on set and we were doing it it just
it felt very comfortable and very normal
very quickly
i would imagine too it would have been
you know a lot harder if you hadn't been
able to already establish this
relationship before you then having to
do all these new safety protocols
oh absolutely uh yeah and it's weird not
getting to
it is weird that working for people for
three months and not getting to see
their faces until the very last day or
sometimes even then not getting to see
their faces
um
but i think there's a silver lining in a
in in that
because we were quarantined you get to
we got to really get close as a cast and
and spend a lot of time together and
bond and that was nice
you put different directors for each of
the first three films what has that been
like to have
different visions and perspectives on
these characters while you guys are sort
of the constant throughout them
well i'd say it's very normal um
tv shows usually have a different
director for each episode and films
in a franchise i mean it's very rare
that you actually have i'm not sure if
there is like a single franchise that
has one director for all
three four or five movies
um
but yeah every director brings their own
style and their own thoughts and visions
to it so it's interesting it's really
fascinating as the actor to get to see
how that changes each film and
how the the sets run
what do you think makes tessa different
in this film both individually and in
her relationship with hardin were there
things that you
specifically enjoyed exploring about
with her at this point in her life
i like that she's older in these movies
because uh
she's a slightly different character
you're not playing a girl who's going
into high school not high school sorry
he's coming out of high school when he's
going straight into college you
you get to play someone a little bit
older and that's nice because
there's just
i don't know it's more similar i guess
to where you're at in life
um
and
sorry what was this with the
relationship well just you know what you
enjoyed about exploring with her at this
point because she is this is a quite a
different stage in her life for her
yeah i think
the other thing i enjoyed is that in the
relate we got to have more fights me and
hero we got to get into more like
specific fights with and extended scenes
and like
conflicts and like this is the problem
because they're already in the
relationship and that's really nice and
like having these moments
where you see them
brushing their teeth together or
lying in bed talking together it's
really nice to get to show like a
relationship between two
adults and all the little
intimate moments that happen in a
relationship
was it important to to you to have her
be at a point in her life where she
doesn't want to give up herself and her
dreams just because she loves him
um
i would say it's somewhat out of my
control because i would say that's kind
of the story and if the story wasn't
that that would be well i wouldn't
i i wouldn't want to change it if there
was a reason for it being that but i
think i think that's
yeah the credit goes to the story that
is what it's about she um
she's balancing she has to ask herself
this really hard question of
what do i want to value what do i value
more and can i make these two things
work um a relationship and love or a
career and i think that
she is the one who
who chooses
career or to at least try to make it
work do you feel like you and hero have
been on the same page when it comes to
your characters and their relationship
and
when their feelings and reactions are
justified and when they're not do you
ever disagree about
the reasons behind their behavior
well we don't talk about that because
i guess our jobs is it's my job to
understand why tessa
is doing something she's doing and why
it's completely justified and it's his
job to understand why harden's doing
something he's doing and why it's
completely justified so there is no
objective answer and if we were to talk
about it and try and try to like
objectively discuss well who's right in
this argument it would make it harder
for us to do this we have to each
believe that we're coming from
the correct place
um and i think when you do that that's
how you are able to do scenes like that
one of the things that struck me
watching the the scene that you guys
have together
that involves the ice cube how long do
you have to do something like that is it
a real ice cube like what are the
challenges of having to deal with
something like that in the scene you
know everyone has been asking about this
ice cube
and i think hiro picked it when we were
doing the scene he was like hold on how
are we going to do this because the ice
cube's going to melt in five seconds
we did one take one close-up i think of
it on skin or maybe two and then that's
it that the ice cube was not there for
the rest of the scene there was there
was nothing in his hand if there was it
was probably glass or plastic
i think it's just movie magic
i think for me i've had my skin burned
with an ice cube so it's like how do you
get through that yeah so it's good to
hear i'm not gonna lie it won't when we
did this one take and she's meant to
look like she's enjoying it and it's
freezing yeah i did struggle not to
scream
which i can completely understand
i i actually really love the friendship
that's developed between tessa and
kimberly what have you enjoyed about
exploring that when it seems like really
the most genuine friendship she has is
somebody who doesn't really want or
expect anything from her
yeah it's interesting because it's a
it's a really wonderful friendship that
tessa has with kimberly but um she's
obviously
older she's she's an older and i love
that sometimes that can happen in life
and like i have a lot of older female
friends
um
and as as opposed to people i think
around my age
and
i think it's nice because
she's she's a friend but she's also
older so she has this mature perspective
which i think is really helpful
for tessa in her life and especially
with the stuff she's dealing with with
hardin but it's not just one way it's
not like a mother-daughter relationship
because tessa then helps her when she's
having to deal with stuff with fans it's
it's very it's a mutual relationship
um and ariel was so great and it was
just wonderful getting to do
scenes with her
yeah it's been so interesting to watch
because it's such a beautiful bond that
forms between them and obviously it's
not like the main relationship of the
story but it's nice to see this
relationship that
just kind of naturally forms
yeah
obviously this film is left on a
cliffhanger there's a shocking moment at
the end of it and we know that we're
getting a fourth film so
is there anything you would tease fans
for the fourth film any kind of hope you
would give them for fans that will be
watching us and and screaming that it
ends where it does honestly i have a
feeling that fans of these movies have
read the books and if they haven't they
will go straight home and read the books
um i remember when i was watching harry
potter or the hunger games or something
i i hadn't read harry potter i went home
and i read the final book because i just
had to know what happened after i saw
like the sixth movie and so the good
news is
they can find out the answer but um
but they they also don't have to because
the movie will be out very soon i think
next year
is it fun to get to have those kind of
cliffhangers because movies like this
don't usually
have big cliffhanger moments like that
because they don't know if they'll get
to come back and finish telling the
story usually you don't want to leave
people in a place like that so is it fun
to get to play with the audience in that
way oh we just love we're very sadistic
we love torturing them apparently
um yeah it's a lot of fun getting to
kind of just always leave them on a
cliffhanger and they're never gonna know
and they just have to wait another year
but but i do i do feel bad i do feel bad
for these fans because i know what it's
like
when you're watching something and you
just and it ends at that
moment right when you want to know what
happens next
what's been the most surprising thing
about this fan base that has developed
that you have i've sure heard from a lot
with these movies what has that been
like to
experience
um
the most surprising thing is probably
the positivity the love
like
it's
i mean i'm just constantly
i'm constantly in awe and i'm waiting
for the day
where it's like
my hands just like recast josephine
but um
and they're just so supportive and it
doesn't
like and i i think that's
that's what i like about
fandom and that's what i think is great
about being a fan of something and being
passionate it's like
just just the positivity and the support
and i think that's been it's been so
overwhelmingly
wonderful
well i appreciate you talking to me
about the film and about the character
like i said it's been fun to sort of go
on this journey and watch you guys
through it so i appreciate you talking
to me about it thank you yeah well i'm
sure we'll talk to you next year yeah
thank you so much thanks
you